Memorial Day is upon us yet again and
this year could bring even more
frustration than fun for travelers with
outrageously long security lines topping
two and three hours at a number of major
airports drawing more attention to the
already beleaguered Transportation
Security Administration some airports
are now weighing a radical option firing
TSA screeners and hiring private
replacements instead Bloomberg News
reporter Justin Bachman joins us now
from Dallas with more and Justin great
to see you our airports without the
federal officers any different any less
safe that's the question everyone wants
to know they're not let's see if it's
really the same standards and the same
protocols that all airports have to
follow and the TSA maintains you know
Authority for keeping those airports
just as safe as all the rest of all so
how does this happen let me let me do a
little personal story so the last time I
traveled was April 2014 then I had a
baby and stuff and then I traveled again
last month and the difference in two
years was unbelievable I had never seen
lines that long since I was a kid what
happened well what happened is the TSA
lost a lot of people and they lost
budgets so this is really a staffing and
a budget issue and that's that's kind of
what we're seeing you know the the
issues I'll come home to roost right now
coming home to roost right now so if
airports are going around the TSA and
looking to hire private screeners what
does the TSA say about this do they
support this option
well they said a lot about this option
yet but I think over time you're going
to hear more talk about whether this
could be part of the solution maybe not
everywhere and maybe not the largest
airports but it could potentially free
up staffing and resources in some areas
to give you more people in other places
and you know that's really kind of what
right now I think everybody is just
scrambling to see what could solve this
problem and get us through the summer I
mean some of this video is like crazy
with all these people what airports have
actually gone more with private
contractors versus TSA and what's been
the result of that well most of the
airports now they're 22 and they're
fairly small San Francisco in Kansas
City are the two largest ones in the
program now
so the people when you're going through
those airports you don't really notice
the difference the only difference might
be slight variation in the uniform but
the standards are the same and you know
what's happened is that a lot of the
airports that are talking about this are
saying we may get better customer
service and we may get more of a
response when we see problems from a
contractor than we do from the TSA but
that's still an open question still an
open question but if enough airports
decide to move away from the TSA and go
to the private security screeners option
what does that compel the TSA to do
anything is a response that the TSA
needs to give well they they generally
transition in a year and they've been
you know they've been approving more of
these now they don't have any currently
pending we say what you're really faced
with is that it's still a budget issue
the money that would pay the private
contractors is still the same money
that's paying that the TSA screeners so
if you don't get more money it's not
clear that you're gonna actually solve
your your long week problem because the
staffing and you know well it's of
course one option that's been thrown out
there is that people can sign up more
for the TSA PreCheck where you are
pre-screened and therefore you can go
into the fast line of course you have to
pay up for that right $88 so no one is
it not a lot of people have actually
done that which is sort of a disaster
Bay at the problem alright so if I'm
traveling on a plane this weekend and
then that Airport decides to switch over
to private contractors how soon do I get
to feel the relief you're not gonna see
a change it's probably gonna be a year
so maybe we'll be talking about this
change at those airports